قد يصبح شراء احدى هذه السيارات المستعمله
رفاهيه بنسبه الى غالب اللبنانيين رسومها
الجمركيه سترتفع بشكل قياسي بموجب
الموازنه العامه في احد المعارض في بيروت
يخشش حاد انعكاس الرسوم على مبيعاته التي
تراجعت اصلا نتيجه الازمه الاقتصاديه
كيف بده يشتري سياره
بال 2005 و3000 على السياره اللي هي حد
الادنى
بما فيها السلع والغذائيه عشره اضعاف
اثاره امتعاضه كثير من اللبنانيين تقول
السلطات ان هذه الرسومه ضروريه لتمويل
الزياده التي اقرتها على رواتب موظفي
القطاع العام زياده سيبددها الغلاء وفق ما
يرى ناجي الناظر في احدى المدارس الرسميه
والتقديمات الصحيه والاستشفائيه
وارتفاع
لبدل النقل بما يتناسب مع الانفجار الحاصل
في اسعار المحروقات
ويؤكد الخبراء ان التضخم كبيرا سينتج عن
هذه الموازنه لاسيه مع غياب الاصلاحات
التي طلبها صندوق النقد الدولي شرطا
لتوقيع اتفاق نهائيا مع لبنان
واسقط السن من حساباته على اساس تكون
موازنه ال 2020 هي بدايه البرنامج
الجزيره بيروت